but first another day and yet another
embarrassing big blunder from
yes the frail the weak the cognitively
struggling
commander-in-chief someone might just
want to remind joe that he's the
president now
somebody might want to whisper that in
his ear before he goes out publicly
again
now when president harris and i took a
virtual tour of a vaccination center in
arizona
not long ago maybe joe's
i don't know maybe just a moment of
honesty who knows right
after all kamala harris she's taken all
the solo calls with world leaders and
she's holding weekly meetings with the
secretary of state
i guess maybe this possibly could be the
harris administration
after all we'll let you decide i took it
to instill public confidence in the
vaccine
president-elect harris took it took hers
today for the same reason
harris biden administration is going to
relaunch that effort a harris
administration together with joe biden
as the president of the united states
the biden harris administration
keep saying it when are we going to
believe it anyway tonight whoever
actually is in charge of the harris
biden administration administration may
want to put the brakes
on this so-called biden blitz we've been
hearing about
because the short daily little public
events of his they're getting
pretty difficult to even watch and
during this week's big interview
with former clinton hack democratic
operative turned abc
news host george stephanopoulos biden
yes struggled again to answer some
pretty basic
simple questions this despite the help
of a cheat sheet
that joe seemingly referenced throughout
the entire interview
but if you watch good morning america
you might not know about the cheat sheet
why because abc well
they did biden a big favor they edited
out references
to joe's trusty little note cards by the
way
i've interviewed presidents before i've
interviewed president bush i've
interviewed president trump
not one time did i ever see them with a
with a note card or a cheat sheet
is anyone surprised though at this point
the biden protection program is alive
and well as i
call it just as the candidate protection
program
existed all during the election
protected by the media mob protected by
big tech and meanwhile
during the same interview biden
referring to vladimir putin as a killer
here's the response from putin he calls
challenges
biden to a debate now pay close
attention to this i think there's more
to this
now according to the russian dictator
quote well i don't want to put this off
for long i want to relax a little this
weekend so we could do it tomorrow or
monday
we're ready at any time convenient for
the american side
now the question is this why would
vladimir putin immediately call
for a debate with joe biden no time to
prepare
what have i been saying what have some
of us half the american people saying
the media mob in this country
they protect all things radical
socialist joe biden
and his administration they're trying to
purposely ignore
what is obvious that now poll after poll
shows that half
of us the american people see apparently
i'm just one of the few people willing
to say it all publicly
when you compare joe biden to 2012 even
2016
joe biden looks extremely weak frail
often confused
and yes he is struggling cognitively it
is obvious
this is not brain surgery now here's the
problem we all have this world has many
evil
actors this many hostile regimes
like putin's russia like the muellers in
iran
like president xi and china like north
korea and kim jong-un guess what
they're not pollyannish about joe biden
they study joe biden they watch our
every move every day
all of america's enemies all of the
world's hostile actors
they are seeing what we are willing to
talk about openly
about joe biden struggling kind of a
shell of his former self from years gone
by
who's working clearly very hard to get
to the weekend
now we're going to ask this important
question is any of this good for the
country
is any of this good for the free world
the answer
that is obvious as well not at all
vladimir putin is a hostile foreign
actor one we should all be concerned
about
and now he's literally openly mocking
the president of the united states for
his own amusement
and frankly i find it as an american
citizen humiliating
how is biden going to respond time will
tell but this is why a
candidate can never be allowed to hide
in their basement an
entire campaign and never be asked tough
questions
oh only now we find out about hr1
the most transformational voting
corruption scheme i think ever
designed by any political party now we
find out about court packing now we find
out about
ending the legislative filibuster now we
find out
about all of these radical things that
he hid during the campaign
this is why candidates in all parties
need to be vetted
and vetted fairly this is why we cannot
not ignore what is happening with joe
biden
the world is a better place when this
country our beloved country
the united states of america is strong
the world
needs a strong america and it's hard to
present a strong national image when a
commander-in-chief
needs no cards just to remember his own
tax plan of course this putin biden
debate will never happen
it can happen i don't think it would go
well but it wasn't so obvious to
press secretary circle back gen saki
she told reporters she need to circle
back on this
issue take a look president putin has
just extended an invitation to president
biden to continue their conversation
but this time he wants to do it live
he's asking for a live streamed
conversation an open direct dialogue
putin says he's available tomorrow
or monday is this something that you
would consider
i'll have to get back to you if that is
something we are entertaining
i would say that the president already
had a conversation already with
president putin even if
as there are more world leaders that he
has not yet engaged with
let me just tell you the straight up
truth hell will freeze over
before joe biden's ever allowed to
debate vladimir putin
why because vladimir putin would clobber
him in any debate that's sad
at this point now you have jen saki
doing a disservice to the administration
and you the american people
she doesn't even try to answer the most
basic of questions
now i think we all know why the white
house wanted questions from reporters in
advance remember the daily beast story
but tonight i do have some good news for
joe biden
tomorrow's friday guess what joe you get
to go home to delaware or camp david
you get days now you can rest and sleep
and nap and drink
hot cocoa and warm milk and take lots of
naps
and by the way you can also spend some
time memorizing a few of those lines
you're going to need
for your first official press conference
which will be held
one week from today